wie ihr ja wisst befasse ich mich
unfassbar gerne mit dem Thema Retouren
das ganze mache ich jetzt schon seit
über drei Jahren und ich konnte in der
Zeit wirklich einiges dazu lernen eine
Sache die ich auch gelernt habe an Apple
Retouren kommen nur die wenigsten man
muss lange dabei sein und braucht gute
Kontakte damit es sich auch wirklich
lohnt und man nicht zu viel bezahlt ich
konnte jetzt über einen Freund einen
24-teiliges Apple Paket ordern und ich
hoffe mal das wird sich lohnen und damit
ja Leute was geht herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen Video ich hoffe euch geht's
allen gut ich habe natürlich alles schon
mal vorbereitet hier haben wir dieses
magische Paket und ich muss wirklich
sagen das ist echt nicht einfach sowas
zu bekommen ist ja logisch Apple ist
super beliebt und selbst wenn Sachen
defekt sind ich weiß hier in dem Paket
sind auch super viele Sachen die nicht
mehr einwandfrei funktionieren sind sie
trotzdem noch immer ziemlich fertig und
dann findet richtig schnell jemanden der
das abkauft um es dann eventuell selber
zu reparieren und weiter zu verkaufen es
gibt so viele so Handyshops wo einfach
nur von morgens bis abends iPhones
angekauft werden repariert werden und
dann teurer verkauft werden aber gut
deswegen würde ich sagen gar nicht lange
und schauen einfach mal rein ich habe
wirklich gar keinen Plan was drin ist
ich ich weiß natürlich was ich oh ja
mein Messer ist mal wieder im Lager ich
mache halt hier so selten eigentlich
noch was auf in dem Büro aber das Paket
ist jetzt ein bisschen kleiner deswegen
geht das so UPS kaputt jawoll shift
kaputt wir haben es gleich so jetzt
haben wir es da machen wir das doch mal
auf WoW okay schaut mal hier Leute
das sieht doch krass aus alter ich weiß
gar nicht womit ich anfangen soll ich
würde sagen wir fangen erstmal mit den
kleineren Sachen an und ich weiß dass in
diesem Paket insgesamt auf jeden Fall
über 20 Apple Produkte drin sind wir
haben hier einmal airpods pro noch mal
Airports pro Airports pro Airports pro
ja überall ist halt ein Schild dran dass
ich jetzt schon Airports pro Airport das
sind gar keine Ehre was ist das denn
normale Airports Apple airpods mit
charging Case 2019 dann haben wir hier
noch mehr airpods pro Airports pro
normale Airport ah hier ist nicht
einfach ist doch ein Schild dran und
noch mal normale airpods alles klar
oh was soll denn das hier fehlt ja das
Case scheiße das war mir von vornherein
klar eins zwei drei vier fünf sechs
sieben acht Mal Airports pro zweimal
normale Airports okay sind schon mal
zehn Sachen was man natürlich direkt
dazu sagen muss ich habe es ja schon
gesagt und man sieht jetzt hier auch
hast alles ist defekt also irgendwie ist
überall ein Problem linkerhörer sehr
leise sonst gut Case Defekt beide Hörer
Defekt oh oh das ging gar nicht gut
höherer schmutzig sonst geht alles aha
linker Hörer schmutzig sonst stimmt
gut okay ich würde sagen bevor wir
weitermachen ich checke einfach mal guck
mal das sieht jetzt super aus Ängste
okay die sind schon auch echt Alter das
cases ist krank dreckig schaut euch das
mal an wie okay ich weiß nicht ob man es
auf der Kamera jetzt so gut sieht aber
es ist wirklich enorm dreckig ich
connecte die jetzt mal mit meinem Handy
und dann schauen wir mal ob die
vielleicht nicht doch funktioniert wir
werden sie hier schon angezeigt
verbinden bin connected einfach mal rein
ins Ohr auch wenn die vielleicht ein
bisschen dreckig sind ja das geht schon
aber
sowas habe ich ja noch nie gehört Alter
das neues Kennzeichen voll rein AUA ich
hör jetzt mal Musik hä
Musik geht nur wenn man jetzt redet hört
sich das ein bisschen komisch an als
würde es in den Ohren so Rauschen aber
wenn man nur Musik hört alles easy ja
empfehlen okay also bei denen wirkt es
so ein bisschen so als sei das Noise
Cancelling einfach defekt ja aber gut
übrigens ich habe eine richtig gute
Challenge für euch wir machen jetzt
einfach mal weiter hier haben wir jetzt
beispielsweise wow airpods Max hier ist
kein Schild dran warte mal jetzt bin ich
aber mal gespannt meint ihr es könnte
sein dass die funktionieren wow guck mal
die sind alle die sind perfekt
eingepackt super Zustand und wir haben
davon sogar gleich zwei oh ein iPhone
und Apple friends was ist das hier ist
auch noch ein Paket unten iPad unten
MacBook
Digger okay ich habe auf jeden Fall eine
krasse Idee für euch ich möchte nämlich
mal wieder ein bisschen mit euch in den
Kommentaren interagieren wir checken
jetzt erstmal ob die hier funktioniert
ich hatte noch nie eigene Airports Max
ich bin ja ein absoluter Apple Creek wie
macht man die dann an aber er hat Snacks
habe ich mir noch nie gehört ach die
sind schon okay sieht gut aus ach komm
bitte funktioniert die Kosten auf 600 €,
okay Airports Max verbindet
schon geräuschkontrolle okay
58% geladen hier kann man es wunderbar
sehen weiter wow das klingt gut ey wenn
die sind einwandfrei
scheiße ey das geht nur rechts hallo
warum gehen die denn nur rechts hier
stand doch gar kein Schild dran Mist ey
die sehen so gut aus ne ich war mir fast
sicher dass sie wie neu sind und dann
geht der linke Hörer aber nicht naja
egal auf jeden Fall was ich sagen wollte
und zwar Leute schätzt doch mal in den
Kommentaren auf den Cent Betrag genau ja
ich habe einen Betrag bezahlt mit Cent
sogar dahinter was habe ich für alles
zusammen ausgegeben und der erste ihr
dürft nur einen Kommentar schreiben wenn
ich sehe ihr habt zwei geschrieben seid
ihr direkt raus der oder die erste die
genau diesen Betrag errät bekommt von
mir ich finde es gut wenn jetzt einfach
wie macht man das eigentlich so ich
finde es gut wenn diese Airports jetzt
einfach funktionieren würden diese
Airports Max guck mal die sind auch
super aus weil dann würde ich die halt
raushauen oder sonst dieses iPhone komm
bitte funktioniert hallo
die Taste 5 Sekunden gedrückt eins zwei
drei vier fünf habe ich doch so
wir sind verbunden oh geil die
funktionieren
okay super ich bin beruhigt also alleine
das hier sind jetzt schon mal keine
Ahnung die haben auf jeden Fall noch ein
stabilen Zustand die haben bestimmt auch
ein Wert von 450 Euro oder also Leute
kommentiert einfach diesen Wert und
Kanal abonnieren ganz wichtig falls dann
wer den richtigen Betrag kommentiert ich
löse das auf insta auf Alex wie ich muss
hier ein ganz kleinen Haken dran machen
damit ich weiß dass sie funktioniert und
airpods Max die defekt sind die sind
doch auch noch was wert oder keine
Ahnung werde ich noch rausfinden hier
haben wir jetzt auf jeden Fall als
nächstes ein iPhone 13 Mini ich hoffe
mal das funktioniert von hinten sieht so
aus von vorne sieht's so aus hier an
hier ist auf jeden Fall kein Zettel
drauf das ist doch schon mal gut guck
mal geht an charging cable ist dabei
sieht super aus Deutsch ja also ich muss
ich würde sagen das Ding funktioniert
iPhone
13 Mini gebraucht liegen wir bei
generalüberholt okay ich habe bei mir
hinten einen Leck drin 512 €. ich bin
mir ziemlich sicher dass du auf jeden
Fall noch 400 € Wert geil und es
funktioniert aber wir sind ja noch
längst sich am Ende Alter so viele Apple
Geräte auf einem Haufen hatte ich noch
nie wirklich nice Döner eigentlich ist
man ja auch voll das markenopfer dadurch
aber mich macht das richtig glücklich
aber natürlich gibt's im Leben auch viel
viel wichtigere Dinge linker Hörer
defekt was haben wir denn hier drin aber
wahrscheinlich sind hier noch mal
airpods drin oder ähm
Grover kennt ihr das nervt mich auf
jeden Fall ein bisschen mit Werbung
immer wenn ich auf insta unterwegs bin
kommt so eine Gruber Werbung und dann
soll ich mir da irgendwie für 80 € im
Monat ein iPhone ausleihen kann man sich
doch auch gleich dann kaufen oder
Hinweis auf jeden Fall noch mal airpods
die lege ich einfach mal hier neben und
wir machen weiter also ich bin mir
gerade unsicher ob ihr nur ein Keyboard
drin ja es ist nur ein Keyboard drin
oder ja ich dachte wir wären iPad drin
ach mann Keyboards von Apple sind auch
gar nicht mal so günstig ich mache
erstmal noch die Produkte die hier jetzt
noch rumfliegen wir haben 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
mal ein Apple der funktioniert
wahrscheinlich der funktioniert
wahrscheinlich auch der hier hat noch
Garantie irgendwas ist gebrochen Obst
deswegen aber nicht so gut auch noch
Garantie funktioniert nicht und die
sollten anscheinend alle funktioniert es
zumindest kein Kleber dran was kostet
ein Apple pencil zweite Generation erste
Generation erste Generation zweite
Generation ja okay also neue kosten die
80 bis 150 kommt auf die Generation an
ja gut okay ich bin mir nicht sicher das
sind die beiden letzten Sachen die haben
wir auf jeden Fall noch ein iPad pro
bildschirmfehler Gesichtserkennung geht
nicht scheiße eine Delle Fernbedienung
gesprungen lädt nicht auf Gerät hat
Kratzer ein Apple TV was kostet ein App
Alter also zu Apple TVs muss ich sagen
da bin ich raus hatte ich noch nie aber
ich wollte immer mal einen testen
deswegen machen wir das doch gleich mal
weil hier stehen ja eh ein paar Mängel
drauf ich checke den mal aus schaue mal
ob der wirklich defekt ist also ich habe
den Apple TV auf jeden Fall jetzt mal
angeschlossen ich muss sagen
funktioniert alles einwandfrei nur es
ist tatsächlich so wenn man jetzt die
Fernbedienung abnimmt kann man den es
geht ja sogar das stand ja dabei dass
der Akku von der Fernbedienung kaputt
ist ich habe jetzt mal aufgeladen und
wie man sehen kann funktioniert aber
notfalls kann ich das Ding ja auch mit
meiner Fernseh Fernbedienung steuern das
ist auf jeden Fall mein erster Apple TV
hier aber ich muss sagen ich glaube ich
brauche sowas nicht aber jetzt haben wir
ihn getestet und funktioniert
überraschenderweise einwandfrei und zu
guter Letzt haben wir hier jetzt noch
ein iPad pro von 2020 schauen wir mal
und hier soll jetzt auch was mit defekt
sein man denkt ja auf den ersten Blick
Leute schaut das hier mal an wie nice in
was für einem perfekten Zustand kann
etwas sein aber anscheinend soll es ja
defekt sein kostet neu auf jeden Fall
899 Euro ist aber leer ich muss mal kurz
Aufladen okay Leute iPad ist an
funktioniert auch echt richtig smooth
jetzt muss ich noch mal kurz checken
bildschirmfehler Gesichtserkennung geht
nicht keine Ahnung testen wir das doch
mal face ID ah ein Problem wurde
festgestellt mit True deep Kamera face
ID wurde deaktiviert ah okay ja schade
und man kann tatsächlich hier ganz unten
leicht erkennen ich habe meine andere
schon ausgemacht dass hier der
Bildschirm leicht heller ist aber sonst
ja ich brauche jetzt auch nicht
zwingenface die muss ich sagen also ist
natürlich schade ich glaube das wäre
sonst auf jeden Fall das Highlight
gewesen im Paket wobei ist es
wahrscheinlich jetzt auch na ja das
Wasser schon wir haben jetzt 24 Apple
Produkte rumliegen und ich schau mal was
ich damit mache eine Sache noch ich habe
mittlerweile auch wieder einen eigenen
Shop wo ich halt dann die Sachen aus
meinem Videos manchmal verkaufe da
gibt's allerdings auch jede Menge
anderen Saft von ihr auf Youtube gar
nicht mitbekommen also ich mache ja
super viel mittlerweile mit Agenturen
und so remmi24.de ist auch in der Video
Beschreibung verlinkt und so Sachen wie
das iPhone kann ich mir vorstellen dass
sie da landen vielleicht auch die
airpods Max oder ich mache so ein
Package Ding wo ich halt einige Sachen
auf einmal verkaufe klar hier sind jetzt
wieder defekte dabei aber man kann ja
auch mit Basteln ich bedanke mich fürs
zuschauen wenn ich die Chance habe sowas
hör mal zu kaufen vielleicht auch noch
mehr werde ich es auf jeden Fall tun
weil ich denke dass es sich halbwegs
Lohn wird für mich wir sehen uns
nächsten Sonntag wieder gibt's ein nices
travel Video das wird echt nice deswegen
da könnt ihr euch auch freuen und haut
rein Leute ciao